make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and
that trailer music for shang chi
absolutely slaps dude it is so good
it reminds me of wu-tang clan from back
in the day right like i wouldn't be
surprised if the soundtrack was by the
rizza it was amazing
but we don't have enough time or i would
need more time to make a proper shang
chi explain video so we'll do that video
like once the trailer or once the movie
actually releases for right now we'll
cover his origin story right and i think
that'll that'll suffice it enough to
give you guys a good idea of who jashan
chi is and and what he's about
so with shang chi's origin story it
originally comes out of what was called
marvel's special edition uh back in the
1970s now the idea behind this is is
that one
um it's written by steve englehart and
and drawn by jim starlin
but one of the things to understand
shang chi was created as a result of the
kung fu popularity in the 70s you could
even kind of go back and look at like
akira kurosawa films but those are more
artistic in nature
um kung fu didn't really hit mainstream
here in the states until end of the
dragon
right like the first real major kung fu
blockbuster film that was backed by
warner brothers it was huge
when it came out um of course it made
sense for marvel to kind of build on top
of that and say well let's release a
comic book series based on this and so
what marvel did here
is they ended up getting the rights to
uh to a character or
several characters created by sax roamer
named fu manchu along with a handful of
others now their original idea was to
basically
do a comic adaptation of the kung fu
show with david carradine
uh that didn't happen of course that
wasn't a possibility right i mean if
you're warner brothers and you own dc
comics why would you let a comic book
competitor create an adaptation of your
product dc would be the ones to do what
you would expect and so the result of
this
is that we end up getting shang chi as
he's depicted here right now when the
story opens up you basically got shang
chi just fighting a whole bunch of guys
here right and able to overpower them
pretty readily but for the most part we
actually end up kind of sidetracking
from that for a second and we have a few
things that go on where he talks about
how he's the son of fu manchu
and how he kind of narrates his own
movements right now the reason why this
was done and why it was written this way
is because with kung fu being so popular
it made perfect sense that marvel would
do their best to kind of throw in an
understanding of what kung fu was about
now they weren't really getting super
philosophical about it and it really
wouldn't even be until later with uh
with shang chi that you would get
philosophical with regards to how it is
that he depicts or how he sees himself
and how he sees kung fu but for the most
part he talks about things like kind of
throwing his weight forward
in order in order to overcome the the
sword of a samurai different things
along those lines right so it's almost
kind of a step-by-step
guide and comic book form uh sort of an
ad hoc version of how to like actually
function
in the realm of of you know using kung
fu and so what we end up getting here
is kind of this flashback right when he
says that he's the son of fu manchu then
we get this flashback where you
basically have shang chi brought before
his father now the crazy thing about
this is that his father basically tells
him that for the last 19
years he's essentially been raised in
isolation he's been trained
by multiple kung fu masters in the kung
fu martial art itself right he's his
mind has been trained it's been owned
the reality of this
is he's just been turned into an
assassin and so what ends up happening
is you have fu manchu you know his
father who basically tells him i need
you to go out into the world and i need
you to kill a guy right i need you to
destroy somebody by the name of dr petry
and the reason behind this or at least
the reasoning he offers is that fu
manchu kind of presents himself as this
guy who's looking to consolidate all the
world's problems
and this is one of the things that was
so interesting about the way that he was
originally depicted
is on one hand you could look at him and
you could say okay so this guy basically
wants to dominate the world and you
could see that as inherently bad but
then you can kind of look at the world
as it exists and say okay so like people
have freedom in the world but look at
what people have done with the freedom
they have
so is it really a good thing
you know if you give people the ability
to live their lives as they see fit then
given the way in which the world exists
and the lives of people live
they'll basically live their lives in a
selfish manner and they won't much care
about anybody else right so people will
inherently
make the world worse and so it's one of
these things where it's kind of like
okay so like if you take freedom away
from people and you force them to live a
certain way but the way in which you
force them to live
actually makes the world better is
stripping people of their freedom an
inherently bad thing
and it's one of the cool things because
you know like an emotional reaction to
that is well of course it's a bad thing
but if you sit down and you think about
it logically and rationally that it's
like
i mean maybe not like maybe it's not
necessarily a bad thing right i sound
like a dictator
i'm gonna conquer the united states
everyone um but nonetheless the the way
this is done
is because of the training of shang chi
and because he was kept in isolation
there's really no external influences
there so there wasn't really anybody to
kind of curtail this philosophy that his
father had and
introduced the notion that his dad might
be wrong and so what you end up having
is him basically traveling to the to the
location
of dr petry and then going after this
guy right with the intention of killing
him now here's an important thing to
understand
pretty much everybody you see in this
story aside from shang chi
are all sex roamer characters and the
reason why that matters is once marvel
lost the rights to saks roamers uh pope
characters all this is gone
right like every every single bit of
it's gone right it's basically just
shang chi
and whatever characters marvel created
to fit into this story
that marvel also owned the rights to and
so that's why you saw this huge paradigm
shift
and how shang chi was depicted in marvel
comics after the rights of fu manchu
were removed and that's why you go into
the
the the further stories you go into
secret avengers um in 2006
2010 uh well you basically end up
getting like this whole retcon where
with fu manchu's character and it all
gets changed and it was never he was
never really fu manchu it was just an
alias you know by zing zoo and that kind
of a thing so
it gets a little wild but the important
thing here is that you basically have
him going into this room and he almost
kind of muses this idea of saying like
this guy's so old and feeble right like
why would i take this guy out like
what's the point of this but then the
the notion that he follows his father's
instructions because essentially his
father
knows best he in turn just says okay
i'll do what i have to and kills this 90
year old man in his sleep with like a
karate chop right he's just like bow
and that's the end of dr petrie right
curtains for this 90 year old man now as
soon as he leaves he's immediately met
by sir dennis naylan smith who again is
also a saxophone character and he
immediately stops him now normally shang
chi and one of the things that's kind of
given to us here
is a change he's one of these guys where
he's not like perfect right but he is
exceedingly aware of his surroundings
and so if he had been paying attention
and he hadn't really been
you know focused on the idea that like
he killed a 90 year old man uh then in
turn he would have heard like the
wheelchair squeaking
or he would have heard this guy
breathing or something like that and he
would have picked up on the fact that
somebody was there right he would have
kept his guard up such as it was he let
his guard down due to distraction and
was basically taken unawares by uh
by by naylan smith right and so shang
chi is able to disarm him and then just
kind of you know
looks you know basically walks away you
know like mission done you know goes to
leave but then he sticks around
and he watches as as you know naylan
goes and
basically kind of muses with with petrie
right looks at him and just it talks
about you know like we've had a great
friendship we had a great run
i failed you you know i was supposed to
keep you alive and i couldn't do it and
while shane chi is watching all of this
he comes to this realization
that maybe he was wrong here and he even
kind of goes as far as to say like you
know why do you weep for this man this
man
was such an evil man right he was such
an evil person he was a foe
of world peace and that's when like
naomi smith is like no you got it all
wrong home slice like your dad is the
bad guy
right like fu manchu is the villain
right he's the bad guy who's doing all
these things right the reality is
i've been fighting this guy since i
first encountered him in burma in 1911.
and i've just been facing off against
him over and over and over again
and all the various forces that he has
at his disposal right the c fan
assassins the whole nine yards and it's
one of these things where he talks about
how fumanchu would basically discover
this elixir that has essentially granted
him vitality and has actually even made
him younger as time has gone on
now one thing to understand in marvel
comics you do have a lot of those
you do have a lot of instances where
somebody will take some kind of a
formula or a substance that will
seemingly keep them youthful
for an incredibly long amount of time
with somebody like wolverine for example
his healing factor is not permanent
right in the sense that if he never had
adamantium bonded to his body and his
healing factor was never
on this constant you know quest to cure
him quote unquote of the adamantium if
that was never the issue wolverine would
live for thousands of years but
eventually he would die of old age right
he's not like deadpool where his healing
factor is just insanely powerful and
it'll last forever
like wolverine ages he just ages much
much slower than anybody
else does at the same time you have like
nick fury right the old school white guy
nick fury who took what was called the
infinity formula which basically granted
him like
eternal youth until he eventually lost
it until he ran out of the formula we
learned that in original sin
and all the youthful depictions of
himself you've been seeing in marvel
comics were just robots life model
decoys
steve rogers of course has a super
soldier serum and he had that until he
lost it to the iron nail
and rick remembers uh captain america
run so you have these instances where
people discover
a form of magic or some kind of a
formula or something like that that
basically grants them eternal youth but
nonetheless you know the the whole point
here is that when this guy nalan was
facing off against uh against fumanchi
over and over again
that he ended up coming into uh in
really into contact with a
uh united states agent named tony mccain
this is not to be confused with
us agent it's just a us agent
but uh but tony mckay was basically
killed right this guy was was killed
in front of naylan and then in turn
naylan had uh he was he was basically
met by the sumo who worked
for fumanchu and that the sumo was
quoted as being this guy who could
basically crush bones to paste and
that's exactly what he did
with uh with with naylan like he
literally crushed the bones in his legs
all the way down to paste where there
was basically nothing left presumably
they healed but they healed in like a
hardened position
uh but nonetheless when shang chi
realizes that his father's the guy who's
behind all this he realizes his father's
a bad guy right he realizes his father's
a villain and so of course he ends up
kind of going back and confronting his
mother and then he kind of asks her like
are the stories about my father true and
she's like i mean basically yeah like
your dad's a dick like your dad's a bad
guy you know and when the question's
asked like why would you as an american
woman marry a man like this
what she establishes is that she
couldn't really love him but she did
hunger for the power that he had right
she wanted the power
that he possessed she wanted to transmit
that power to a child of hers she wanted
to have a son who would be a king now
the crazy thing about this is that if
you go back and you read the old letters
pages
women were pissed when this happened
they were mad as hell uh what few women
were reading comics anyway because it
depicted women as kind of being this
this you know group out there that were
basically gunning for any measure of
power
or money as much as they can regardless
of the price that they pay right even
sacrificing themselves in order to
attain power or money now the reality is
this story was written
for or at least to a degree was written
from the perspective of how like another
culture would see
american women and and again kind of my
my own little take here
um it seems relatively accurate in terms
of how other countries would view
american women right american women are
a lot more aggressive right they're a
lot more like i'm going to get out there
and i'm going to do my thing but a lot
more independent which is not a bad
thing but if you are a person who lives
in a country whereby women in your
country
due to the societal standards and even
just the philosophies in which they live
or even choose to live depending on what
kind of country you're talking about
where they're more docile and they're
less aggressive were they to kind of
just
go with the flow or they're not
necessarily out there you know being
being hyper independent you would see
that as something that seems kind of
wrong or something incorrect again
it's just a cultural thing but the the
whole notion behind this is that she
simply
wanted the power that came with being
able to say that she had a son who was a
king and so ultimately when he picks up
on this he ends up that's when you kind
of pick up in
the current moment where he's going
after all these forces of fu manchu
right taking all these guys on fighting
all these different guys and so on and
for the most part he overcomes them
quite readily now the funny thing about
this in the way that it was done while
the story
was not necessarily indicative of like
well i guess
it was really an incomplete movie but
like the game of death from bruce lee
right like you know a warrior's journey
the game of death while it wasn't
necessarily
done like that because that really
hadn't been released and you know by the
time you know at the point this story
had come out it's very similar to it in
the sense you have shang chi
fighting his way through his father's
castle and facing off against these
various individuals
all of whom have different fighting
styles now the truth about it is that it
really was designed in a lot of ways to
mirror
the the enter the dragon film in the
sense of like an almost
tournament-esque situation working his
way up to like the main bad guy but
regardless of how you slice it he
basically manages to cut his way through
each one of these guys and overpower
them
this is really kind of marvel just
showing us what shang chi was capable of
that he wasn't limited in the sense that
like he can fight somebody who knows
kung fu and he can't really like counter
or fight anybody else
it's designed to show his prowess right
using whatever he can to his advantage
and that's one of the that's the kind of
stuff that you see him talking about
here right like the sumo is stunned i
see is my advantage
and his cue like striking cobra and
that's kind of it it's one of these
things where you see him saying stuff
like that you know the sumo is stunned
so i seize the advantage right that kind
of a thing just kind of using the
different situations and and so on to
his advantage and ultimately coming out
on top
and he does this over and over again
right facing off against various forces
um that are all basically being used by
by fumanchu including like a giant
gorilla right which is really kind of
crazy here now ultimately once he gets
to fu manchu himself there's not really
a fight here
and the reason why is because this was
the introductory issue and the truth is
that marvel didn't know if it would
succeed and so one of the rules when it
came to marvel comics spectre in the
1970s is that
throw out a story and then give it an
open ending and see whether or not
people
want more and the letters pages
indicated that they did and so that's
why you saw the marvel special edition
series running for two more issues
with uh with 16 and 17 and then marvel
just rebranded it right to the master of
kung fu starring shang chi which made
sense right it was just it was literally
just a series of reprints that's all
marvel special edition was for issues
one through fourteen they just reprinted
old stories and then shang chi was when
they introduced a new character and when
they realized it was successful they
were like whatever man keep it going
right we'll just turn it into shang
chi's story i mean we're not really
doing anything else of any meaningful
value with the comics
just make it his and so you kind of have
this conversation that shane she has
with his dad where he asks him like is
it true right
like are you really you know in this for
like world domination are you really a
bad guy and it's one of the things where
he kind of presents this
interesting philosophical idea he's like
yeah but again like people are using
freedom to basically make the world
worse right like there's constant wars
different things like that so yeah like
i am i'm looking to rebuild and to
basically conquer the world and to turn
into an empire that exists under me
right that is run entirely by me now
this is when you start to get into the
delusion of the narcissist because it's
this philosophy of
i'm the only one who can make the world
a better place nobody can make it better
except for me or only my
ideas can make the world better that's a
narcissistic philosophy right the belief
that you
and you alone are the only person
capable of making the world better right
and that
if people don't listen to your ideas
then they're doing it wrong right like
that's just that's just narcissism just
good old-fashioned narcissism which of
course his father has i mean
he's a bad guy right he believes in
conquering the world in order to make it
in his image and that's when shane
chee's kind of like you're crazy right
like that's never going to happen but
again you don't really get a full-on
fight here instead what you have
is you have his father who basically
tells him like if that's how you're
going to be and you're going to stand
against me that's fine
leave my lair in peace and respect but
never ever attempt to
believe that you can somehow come back
into my good graces you are out of here
now and understand
like from this point going forward you
will forever be my enemy and i will take
every single force that i have at my
disposal and i will direct it towards
destroying you and that was really just
the future of the the shang chi stories
right going throughout the entirety of
the master of kung fu run until you got
to issue 118
when fu manchu died uh it was him just
fighting all the various forces of fu
manchu and that was basically it right
that was that was really all the story
was they were interesting i mean it
depends on which ones you were talking
about they were kind of cool but that's
what the story picks up because from now
it's him just kind of going out into the
world and and just kind of understanding
how it all works and and learning about
it all and coming across new characters
and teams and heroes and things like
that but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you